Speaker 1: Remember that The David Pakman Show is
dependent on folks who decide to get memberships
on my website, you can sign up at join Packman
dot com. We do an extra show every day for our
members. We also offer commercial free audio
and video streams of the show for our members.
And when we do viewer town halls like we did a few
weeks ago, members get a separate priority line
to talk to me and lots of other great little perks
of sign up at Join Pacman dot com. You can use the
new coupon code. Wow. 22. To get a significant
discount at join Pacman dot com. Let's look at
some interesting posts from this morning on the
David Pakman Show subreddit. The David Pakman
Show subreddit can be found at David Pakman dot
com slash Reddit. More than 33000 of our viewers
and listeners have subscribed. Their first
post is concerns over right wing friends.
This is an interesting topic. User Atman
writes. Hey everyone, as the title implies,
I have a bit of a serious issue. Growing up, I
had a conservative phase. I was only like 16 and
was pulled in by the 2016 wave of conservatism on
YouTube and social media. I ended up making some
friends at this time with similar interests. We
were pretty much your standard. I'm a classical,
liberal type. Watched Ben Shapiro debates maybe
some Paul Joseph Watson, a lot of Stephen Crowder.
Over time, I drifted away and became a lot more
liberal. These friends, however, did the opposite.
They're extremely right wing. They think it
is a left wing power grab, which is annoying
considering I've worked on a covert unit since
April and see it firsthand. Trump actually won
the election. Armed insurrection is justified, and
I fear they're even beginning to dabble in white
nationalism. Our talks have become noticeably
more tense. All they do is post guns on their
Instagrams and spam their stories with far right
propaganda. Is there any hope of helping them?
Should I just cut them off? If I was able to drift
liberal, could I manage to help them as well?
I appreciate the advice. I mean, listen, this
is a really I get calls like this all the time
from people. This is a really personal thing. I
don't think there's any issue with having friends
with diverse political opinions. I have friends
with diverse political opinions that include,
you know, kind of casual Center-Right Republicans
mostly focused on tax and regulation issues.
People who are sort of outside of the traditional
political space but are just culturally very
liberal or conservative. But I don't have any
friends that are outrageous MAGA lunatics and
white nationalists and all these different things,
because that is so at odds with what I believe
those views often rife with anti-Semitism and
xenophobia and all these things. There's no way
for me to put that aside and just talk about
yesterday's basketball game. There's a sort of
line, and that line is different for everybody.
The question about bringing them to the left,
that's a different question altogether. And it
really comes down to how much work are you willing
to put in when we talk about deprogramming and de
radicalizing people? We're talking about something
that can take months of concerted effort, if
not longer. As I've said before, I think the
most. Kind of least the least confrontational
way to approach this is to just regularly ask.
Basic probing questions about how did you
come to believe that? How did you come to
believe that kind of a soft Socratic method
of questioning, but it's a very personal thing
what you were willing to sort of endure in terms
of getting to that point of having a shot at
disabuse them of these beliefs, but let us know
how it goes. Another post I spotted user Philo
posted an article about Turning Point USA building
the next generation of conservative influencers.
Influencer first, conservative second. I
have talked for years about how the right is
willing to lose money on individual projects,
like throwing tons of cash at these, these
organizations that program young right wingers
to go out and spread the message, so to speak,
because they see it as a bigger investment in
the longer term. The right has a lot of views,
including on abortion, gay marriage, taxes,
health care, where if you just ask questions in an
unbiased way, you see that the country continues
to move to the left, to the left, to the left.
But what is the right doing to continue winning
elections and controlling the narrative? They are
just dumping cash into training up advocates
for their perspectives right out of college,
and we on the left should be very worried about
it. I have conversations all the time with
wealthy ish and very wealthy Center-Left people
and actual progressives as well, and they say,
How can I deploy my resources? And I say, You
know, if you really want to make a difference,
you've got a fund left wing media and create
organizations equivalent to what the right has
to get people to become advocates when they come
out of college. Because the right has the ground
game figured out and they'll sometimes say,
Well, what about George Soros? You know, often
is what's mentioned. Soros is operating on a
very different level. Soros is not doing what
the right is doing with groups like Turning Point
USA and others. So without a doubt, if the Left
really wants to control that space and
actually work to make the country's
sort of sort of public political orientation match
that of what people are privately saying are their
views, because remember, our elected officials are
way to the right of where the country is. We've
got to fight them the way that they fight, which
is dumping a ton of cash into these organizations.
Turning Point USA. It's a vile organization, but
they are doing exactly what the Left fails to do.
Last post was and I got a ton of these. Anybody
know what's up with the subscriber feed on the
website? I thought David was on vacation and I
wasn't paying attention. But there's there are
new segments on YouTube and I'm not finding the
content on the website. It is 2022, so you must
have a message to all members with peace and
love. You have to go to Member Content 2022
to find this year's shows. 2021 is
over. I know a lot of people miss this,
but the content is there. We are back. Join the
discussion at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.